good to chat with John McClane how you
been John Rich I've been great how are
you and tell me how is everything in
Houston this morning hey dark and dreary
days you can imagine losing losing to
the Red Sox the best team in baseball is
one thing but to lose four in a row
after you get the first one at Fenway
including three at Minute Maid Park is
almost unfathomable but the Red Sox kick
their butt and they deserve to win and
move on to the World Series so what's
the what's the post mortem what do you
think the epitaph reads for the 2018
Houston Astros John they want a record
number of games 103 they peaked at the
right time starting in September they
swept Indians and and then they were a
huge disappointment but overall the fans
here are very forgiving they're all
fired up now about spring training
beginning February 23rd and all is
forgiven one day later well I mean they
definitely have the kids they definitely
have the young players that are gonna
turn into veterans of significant note
what do you think they do in this
offseason what happens here in the last
offseason rich Jeff luneau the GM
rebuilt the bullpen the bullpen let them
down big-time in this series
they've got unsigned players Dallas
Keuchel they got to get Marwin Gonzalez
back he's just too valuable at a number
of positions most people think Keuchel
as a left you 30 will get a big contract
somewhere else they've got Evan Gattis
as contract up Charlie Morton he'll be
35 next season but those are the only
guys that really contributed who could
be gone and they their minor league
system is really good as you mentioned
they got a lot of good young players
here they should be good again next
season and one of the favorites to win
the World Series
I talked about it with Ken Rosenthal
earlier John the reputation of the
organization has definitely taken a hit
with the story that was in Yahoo Sports
this week about somebody I've never
heard of getting a credential seemingly
from the owner to take photographs of
opposing dugouts and this is in light of
a lot of teams thinking that the the
Astros are cheaters are they cheaters
John I have no idea I mean they baseball
investigated and said the guy was there
for surveillance which is ridiculous he
was supposed to be making sure the Reds
we're not cheating what were there Apple
watches again I would imagine just about
every team in this era of analytics and
electronics that everybody's doing
something to try to gain an advantage
but when you put a guy in a camera well
and he's not a camera and he's right
next to the dugout shooting then it's
very suspicious and the Indians tipped
him off on that but I was stunned
baseball investigated so quick and I'm
guessing this is not the end the end of
it john mcclane here on the Rich Eisen
show how hurt is deshaun Watson John he
was not on the injury report this week
he went through full participation in
every practice last week he played was a
bruised sternum a broken rib and a
partially collapsed lung and and that
I've been said it's worst game he had
his worst game he only got sacked seven
times and knocked down 12 more times and
yet he said this week he feels so much
better than he did last week it just
seems to me even though his numbers
I guess statistically fantasy wise are
up the offense just doesn't seem to have
clicked so far John is that a fair
assessment rich that offense in the red
zone is pathetic last year when he
played in six starts they were number
one in red zone touchdown 67% now their
31st only ahead of the Jets they've been
only team's been in the red zone more
the Texas is around but can't scored
touchdowns and the closer they get the
worse they are and they show no signs of
improvement so what is the answer I
don't know they get the same quarterback
you got the same play caller and Bill
O'Brien you got another bad offensive
line they can't get a push it's almost
like you get to the one you get a
penalty to penalties on purpose to
backup to get some room and if I'm the
Jaguars Sunday and they get in the red
zone I say come on down to the 1 because
they can't score from the 1 well I'm
assuming the Cowboys took care of any
plays that Bill O'Brien still has on a
sheet that includes number four trying
to run it in from the one right I mean
when you think those were he couldn't
find receiver and he took off and that's
where he got hurt this last game he only
ran twice he said well we had a more
conservative game plan with my running
but Watson has to be smarter with the
ball he's got to get rid of it quicker
there were
on that all week in practice we'll see
against Jacksonville the Jaguars sacked
them 14 times in two games last year
coleus Campbell had six I would imagine
he's a beast that wants to feast
yeah machen so and it seems like JJ
Watts all the way back John is that a
fair assessment
oh yeah rich he's been great he looks
like he did in 2015 when he won his last
Defensive Player of the Year award sacks
tackles for loss quarterback hits forced
fumbles he's been great in every era we
saw every in every area and we saw it in
the second half of the opener against
New England when he started to look like
his old self and now he's back to
getting the double teams about the
tackles and the guards and they need
other players to take up the slack but
he's been tremendous fun to watch again
he's probably not one of the few
defensive players I've ever watched and
not watched the ball but watch him
because he just been so extraordinary
through the years and after knowing what
he went through the last two years I'm
really happy for well John McClain
Houston Chronicle here on the Rich Eisen
show having seen what we did see this
past Sunday night between mahomes Chiefs
Brady Patriots what we might see from
the Ravens against New Orleans this week
what is the viable ceiling for the
Houston Texans in 2018 AFC South which I
thought was going to be a lot better as
mediocre again I think the quarterback
and none of the quarterbacks were
playing well except Andrew Luck but he's
got nothing around him but over the
other three quarterbacks I think the one
that turns it around is going to be the
one that wins the division that could be
bortles he had one of the best games of
his career against the Texans last year
in Jacksonville when Jadeveon Clowney
called him trash and so now he's back
home I expect bortles to play well
against the Texans mm-hmm and you saw
the Cowboys a couple weeks ago right
there in your home state of Texas what
do you think their viability is moving
forward in 2018 I was stunned rich when
I saw the Texas shut down the Cowboys
offense just totally shut down as they
kill Elliott and then Dallas puts up 40
on Jacksonville which has just made the
jaguars even more honoré going into this
game Sunday but anybody looks like right
now other than Giants can win the NFC
East and I picked the Cowboys this year
like I picked the Eagles last year and
right now still think they got a chance
and now let's move on to the Rockets who
are here in Los Angeles this weekend
they're going to be first up for LeBron
and purple and gold right here in LA
that was quite a beat-down they suffered
an opening night against New Orleans
what is the expectation level for the
Rockets that's a nice way to put it beat
down and because it was actually a lot
worse they were playing at Toyota Center
next door to Minute Maid Park and
they're glad that the Astros were
playing because they just got
obliterated so it might be good that
they're out there expectations here
course we're very I they had a Carmelo
Anthony to go with James Harden and
Chris Paul made some other pieces but I
got off to a bad start but people here
still think it's going to be the rockets
and the Warriors and in the Western
finals again so what do you think they
are going to do though John I think with
all their talent with the new pieces
they brought in they needed I think they
I don't know rich I was stunned they got
beat that bad but they got too many good
players Dan Tony's a good coach they
shoot those threes like crazy I think
they'll be right there behind the
Warriors well I mean when it all comes
down to they lost Jeff miss Delic who is
the the supposed a defensive guru for
this team and that switching defense
that we saw worked so well against
Golden State until Chris Paul's
hamstring gave away is that any genuine
concern for you there is too early to
say that they've made remarkable
improvement on defense he even got James
Harden to play defense the last two year
which people didn't know that Harden
could and I think haven't got this Paul
there he's been a tremendous leader and
they brought in a couple players who are
defensive specialists but you never know
when you lose somebody what the impact
is going to be on the team but I think
there's still got so much talent there's
no way they're not going to be right
there at the end all right now is there
any on your your Hall of Fame radar John
what's your best guess now that we're a
midway through the season coming up
obviously we're gonna be having a new
class coming in we've Gil Brandt is is
in this mix for the first time it's
pretty exciting on that front how do you
how do you see that coming I'm so happy
for Gil and Pat Bowlen of Cour
Guil I've known forever like you have I
grew up in Waco Texas Dollard cowboy fan
I started hearing about him in 1960 with
tex ram at Tom Landry and knowing how
much Gil's meant to the game easy in Pat
Bowlen Zinn so I having two contributors
this year I think it's just tremendous
so what do you think when it all comes
down to it with players who might get in
there I think we got locks like Champ
Bailey Tony Gonzalez and there's one
more and I can't remember who it is I
see three locks on there and the rest I
think that Reed is one of them and Reed
is another lock and so that makes it
tough for the guys who are holdovers but
I I know this rich it gets harder and
harder every year because of all the
talent that's not just coming out that
the first time eligible but the guys
that are worth a year in and year out
and unless we increase the ballot which
we're not going to do it's I feel so bad
for those who have to wait but it's so
many have learned the never give up hope
why not increase the ballot now you'd
have to talk to all the fame bosses on
that one that's way above my back would
you would you as part of the selection
committee with the members of the
selection committee like that I can only
speak for myself but knowing how many
guys are worthy that are not in not just
the modern era but the seniors I'd love
to increase it not as many as the
College Basketball Hall of Fame where
they had like there's so many it can't
fit their names in a paragraph so I
would love to see us add more because I
mean when you think about it John you
know and we are broadcasting right now
straight into Canton Ohio on our
affiliate WH BC out there look there's
just over a handful over 300 men in the
history of the National Football League
on which there's 53 that play every
single week for 32 teams I don't think
it would dilute the the sport and/or
that room if you add one or two more
every single year I agree we did 100%
one thing I'd like to see and this came
up when we could created the contributor
category there was a talk about putting
coaches in a contributing category
because it's hard for coach to get in
when they're going against players and
so I wish they were eligible for
and then we'd be able to get more
coaches in there no I just know if you
wear this job before I let you go you
know since you're a man right there in
the Gulf South I asked Wade Phillips
when I saw him for the Thursday night
football game a few weeks ago was Rams
throw back I asked him I'm like can
can't you wear a bum Phillips lid I mean
can't we get a ten-gallon hat made by
Nike or something like that and he said
he would reach out to do something like
that don't you think he should do
something I think he definitely should
do that he's bright got a lot of his
dad's cowboy hats and those big jackets
bum used to wearing when it was cold you
know he's got the boots so yeah I'd love
to see just put the suede Phillips do
that sign a bomb yes son
what's your favorite bump Phillips story
before I let you go you must have he had
a lot of great quotes one time when Earl
Campbell couldn't finish the mile run in
all season conditioning program media
ran up to him and oh my goodness bum
Earl can't finish the mile he goes well
when it's third in a mile I'll give it
to somebody else you hear an Earl
Campbell references in terms of say
qualm Barkley John I'm hearing a lot of
those actually higher a lot a lot of
references to Earl when you have a guy's
got speed and power and it has a lot of
long runs Barclay of course an
incredible prospect and I think we'll
hear more so you think it's fair I think
if this early date no I mean Earl's
rookie year he was MVP
I don't think Barkley is going to be MVP
or lead the league in rushing Earl did
both of those in 1978 and so he's going
to have to earn that comparison last
thing for you John what are you watching
these days waiting for Game of Thrones
next year waiting for your favorite
Khaleesi to come back on television
I can't wait till they put all the
previous episodes on HBO to remind us
what the shows about
he'll miss Ramsay Bolton big-time and
I'm gonna be depressed when that game
when that show is off TV because anytime
they put rerun out there I watch it and
after it's all over rich I'm gonna go
back and read the books okay what are
you watching now what do you watch on TV
today I like to friends of mine created
the Chicago series on NBC
man Chicago fired Chicago PD and I never
miss them because of Derek has and
Michael Brandt those are the ones I
watch the most are you going Hollywood
they all went to Baylor second okay no
I'm not going they fact that Michael
offered me a chance to come to a Rowland
in the last episode of Chicago fired two
years he said you play corpse yeah well
we'll just have them burn you below the
face and then I couldn't get away
because of the draft come on John could
have been a corpse Oh Chicago fire okay
John there's ice there son there's
always tomorrow
Thank You Raj care John you take you
that's John McClane
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience